attention prévient que le toc toc toc
c'est parti mais il vient d'où là il
vient de excusez moi ici il vient nous
vient d'allemagne ou quoi à vous c'est
vous parce que vous déplacer lentement
ce accord alors allez-y
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait des gens quel loupé des gens du
cru mais en fait vous n'êtes pas
déguisée du tout vous bon ben c'est même
un peu quand même
alors reporter au tableau 2 toques ça
fait deux ans qu'elle n'abandonnait on
n'est pas prêt ça fait dix ans qu'elle
de fait dix ans a toujours pas pigé
d'une histoire
oui allez-y c'est ginette une actu
ginette sur le né jésus le passé inconnu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'vous jure je sais pas pour vous j'ai
pas du tout reconnu la chanson
comment voulez des grandes alpes et
repas thanou sait qui c'est ginette
céréales ans et bosh et j nature donné
j'essaye de passer incognito gb les
comptes d aller elle et elle est en
forme
allez deuxième d'octobre est parti d'un
coup c'est vraiment mais non non c'est
bellamy est montré mondiale et c'est moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais on dirait chuck norris sans
rigoler avec bear head shot luis est en
tout cas jouer d'un instrument
oui bien sûr tout à fait mal et bien dit
mais bien évidemment temps d aller j'y
faisais moi je vais faire un peu à la
bourre des neufs ressortaient direct au
top top c'est parti c'est moi c'est très
belle s'agit d'une des voies comme ça
mais qui détecte pas franchement c'est
pas exiger d'une guerre des prix qui est
là c'est tout autant c'est bouder bout
des nerfs qui opère brûlé au vent mais
landes de pierre c'est pour les vivants
un feu d'enfer dominé jo petit j'ai un
petit truc à riga ex
c'était ma meilleure non comme la là
vous êtes en mission de sardou déjà ses
dents mais s'assure sont en deux qu'est
ce qu'on a dit au début de l'année call
c'était pas calme à la festif festif et
vincent gilbert d'applaudissements
oh là là là ça y est on est et on est à
la soirée du baigura le bureau des
élèves dits motta des nouvelles du
canton alors il va le faire son master
ou pas non mais ça est là c'est
obligatoire ça va manger très bien en
tout cas des douze forment un couple
magnifique merci il sans rigoler la
préface est prêt pour halloween à
pontchâteau toc toc c'est parti attendez
attendez attendez
qu'est ce que c'est que cette agitation
là vous reportez vous devrez commencer
chalmé ben c'est comme celle doigts dans
la porte ou quoi non mais attendez à
l'eysée alors en fait le gentiment on a
des plus gentils mode sinon vous
rentrerez pas non
alors allez-y attendait à pascal et
isabelle morini bosc à lèvres ses
breloques
j'entendais depuis tout à l'heure sans
rigoler j'entendais des bruits je vous
dis là quelqu'un qui tient chez en
laisse ou quoi et en fait c'est elle qui
ont enlevé ces colliers tout simplement
elle c'est un truc de fou alesi tac tac
tac qui hélas gens dans un organisme
gens vont s'élever
[Applaudissements]
non
essai - est très agitée c'est bon là la
fille de rené malleville de la stomie
navale et j'embrasse bien sûr tous mes
potes
voilà d'où les toute l'équipe la saison
boitsfort bande organisée s'est monté de
préférence en moins les airs merci mais
vous en ont même pas moi non mais vous
vous lavez saccagés ils avaient saccagé
allez c'est parti les quatre je vois en
tout cas dans ce vraiment il ya du
talent vous vous êtes un formidable
espoir
tous les gens qui nous regardent c'est
pas avec les gens se disent tu vois même
avec rien ou quelqu'un vous dit cette
émission et moi moi je me mets dedans
mais c'est vraiment si je vous dis c'est
100% motivation semo passant de talent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est motivé à mais on part de loin
mais vraiment bravo vous foule vraiment
je ne sais plus allez c'est parti
toc toc j'ai hélas c'est jean-michel
mais non mais pas mais non il s'est
trompé auxquels nos potes qui est la
terreur toutes parts au quai par toute
première fois
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est le bon sens c'est le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
métro les bénévoles effet là où vous
avez mis la barre très très haut alors
mais vraiment et et vous savez
extrêmement bien mais on voit vraiment
vous êtes brabo bah oui mais on voit
qu'il ait pas de l'ipad et des pannes
explicite est donc allé le prochain
macbook touch
c'était 4 oui tu es là c'est yan yan
trop de gens qui t'aiment
[Applaudissements]
je ne me
katia quatre mystérieux dirait christian
clavier bravo mais revenons de très
élégant mais en tout cas c'était le
meilleur - de vue d'un point de vue
sonorités ces nouveautés
c'est dire le niveau j'aimerais le mal
c'est quand même beau tu es beau tu es
aussi allez c'est parti
d'autant qu'elle est jésus jésus ni j'ai
6 ans
[Applaudissements]
j'ai offert deux aveux le premier c'est
jamie chronique ça fait mal et le
premier s'est tu te fout de notre gueule
ça c'est le premier degré et 2 tu sais
que je kiffe ce titre - c'est vrai à moi
aussi je les écoute tous aller
je suis vraiment cette chanson il est
drôle fait jeu michalak i am aussi mais
eux-mêmes vraiment parfois ça va
compliquer une vraie vous pascal et hop
non mais il vaut mieux s'arrêter vous
savez vaut mieux faire une populaire
regardez vous savez vous comment vous
parce que le chant classique sur la
chaîne se disent quand même elle est
très très attaquée parce que tu me fais
les chéris john bender thierry
bienveillant et après tout la bralima
bien entendu patata micro parce que
tommy bowe et en main on n'a pas donné
pendant des années on voulait pas leur
chanter l'instrument des ouïes de
ventilation est lui nouvel album merci
en tout cas jean pascal est branlant
paix si ça va vous notre ennemi vous
ramener à la maison
ne vous inquiétez pas d'aller voir les
gens très sympas bangkok
c'est comme qui comme comme qui comme
s'ils n'existaient pas
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'on attendait mais ça c'est
khaled ben sassi khaled ben sassi khaled
les mecs mais il n'ya pas mais c'est à
dire qu'il n'ya rien du berceau semblait
s'envoler même isabelle comme ça non m
c'est mais ça va les yeux un bel et bien
mais alors si vous avez un petit truc
que vous croyez que vous êtes tous les
wagons à les séparer
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle attendent les pavés mais
khaled il avait d offrir ou saad allah
beaucoup plus de la loi pénale
allez c'est parti c'est le dernier de la
soirée on y va docteur kay ces gens sont
bien gentils
oui genton ses voix genton qui j'entends
le loup lé succès sur non mais
franchement je vous jure par dieu sur la
sellette des enfants ça vous va hyper
j'aime beaucoup et non mais sans rigoler
terminons qu'elle ça c'est bien surtout
travaillé sa liste médias c'est quand m
[Applaudissements]
m